true story apparently former President
Barack Obama has signed a production
deal with Netflix yeah Obama and talk
super hard show for Netflix well earlier
today netflix released a trailer for
their very first project with President
Obama guess what we have the exclusive
rights to its world premiere yes we do
yeah
no thank you thank you I'll tell you
something this is an amazing trailer
it's not at all what anyone was
expecting from Barack Obama I think it
looks incredible take a look
[Applause]
No
people asked me what it was like to be
the most powerful first in the world and
I say I'm not sure
let me ask Michelle as the show always
says presidents can't live with them
can't you if Donald Trump is watching
before I left office I hired Rahm
Emanuel to pee on the mattress you've
been sleeping on this whole president
can provide just one small piece of
advice it's this you've got to wash that
ass right don't you hate it when they
get your name right at Starbucks right
now since Starbucks last week and when
my drink came up instead of Obama they
just written the greatest
very good
you